was that hard to always be a great bad
guy or did you sort of relish in that
yeah yeah so boring right because people
expect you to be nice a picture with the
baby but it's a bad guy you can do
anything
mmm and it's okay you know I mean and
then you get to see how far you can take
people you know I mean some people freak
is kind of bugs people freaks them out a
little bit uh thinking about starting a
riot but that's when you know you've
done your job right when you can get
people to step out of their comfort zone
and come into the ring after you now
you've done the job did you have that
happen oh yeah how many times probably
30 40 times 30 40 times people charged
the ring yeah well we got bad couple of
times one time the worst one being in
Dallas Texas which is like 60 miles from
my hometown what started it I was
wrestling sting and the guy stood up
about nine rows back reached inside of
his jacket pulled out a 9-millimeter and
got three shots off before they got him
oh I'd already dived underneath the ring
steam being the big face and stupid yeah
he's enduring whoo [ __ ] you sting I'm
not coming back [ __ ] you know this guy
got three shells off at me I remember
going to the back to myself you take
them that for you making people do [ __ ]
they would not normally do because if
they guess again off they got him
but here's what they brought him to the
bag they're like shake you know to press
charges I might press charges
no just reload the [ __ ] put him
back out there what the [ __ ] do you
think pressure of course I want to press
charges man he put three holes in the
building of the old [ __ ] of
Sportatorium their doubt was he shooting
at you or was he just shooting at the
ceiling at me yeah we have hated my ass
I had a woman cut me with a box cutter
what yeah and the first time she'd ever
been to watch wrestling what what did
you do to start that she had been at
home with her grandkids and
watch me wrestle like Oh granny look at
so-and-so Jake Roberts he's oh he's so
bad if somebody needs to watch his damn
mouth Alice open spanked his ass what
that man needs you know somebody should
straighten him out earlier in his life
and they're like oh granny shut up you
wouldn't done anything he'd run from him
to I would not run from that man
and they basically challenged the
grandmother not knowing it
she's a little off next time I come to
town she gets a [ __ ] ticket she's
gonna show those grandkids she's not
afraid of me oh Jesus Christ I came down
the aisle I got security around me and
all of a sudden my Security's : is this
[ __ ] great most of you have turned to
see what they're doing
there's his old woman that's down and
they're all over I don't think he had a
[ __ ] heart attack man what's going on
hey guys what's going but cutting you
man
oh my oh you're full of [ __ ] look at
your arm
holy [ __ ] 30 stitches Jesus Christ arch
cutter you just didn't realize it you
don't feel it about it's like sharp yeah
so I get to the back with her it's not
your the story you know what happened
what actually happened and I just looked
at everything can I hug ya hugged her I
started crying and she started crying
and whoa Jesus was that wife number two
or three that's why it only lasted for
months blades what the [ __ ] man well
you're a better man than me what you did
kick her though yeah false teeth jiggle
too yeah